so you followed the instructions in part
one to a t
now it's time to get a little bit more
creative using what we've already
created in arcade we can start
developing and moving forward our
bathroom design now speaking from
experience is significantly cheaper and
significantly easier to leave all your
plumbing fixtures exactly where they are
that means if you have the toilet on the
left the shower in the middle and the
basin on the right hand side you should
in reality leave them exactly where they
go to relocate the shower and relocate
the vanity is a huge cost but at the
same time in my personal opinion if
you're doing a renovation you're doing
it right and you're not just doing a
cosmetic renovation that'll basically
just be a different set of colors and
materials rather than a functional
change to that space that would improve
the overall architecture in itself so
that's why in this tutorial we're going
to break it down destroy half of this
bathroom entirely and re-plan an
entirely different space that works
functionally for all users so at the
moment we're basically just going to get
rid of everything we are going to
completely knock everything down
personally what i would do is i would
highlight everything delete those items
from site you can see that they still
appear as a trace reference so we've
come up to window toolbars and palettes
and then activate our trace and
reference we can throw that to the top
of our bar and untick the trace button
so we no longer see what was there
previously at the same time i'm going to
demolish all of those internal walls
that we created highlighted all my
internal tiles and my mirror as well i
am going to leave this wall just there
for the time being so i can actually
indicate where that wall goes so if i
delete all of those items reuse one of
these walls and draw a brand new wall in
here i'm going to put that 800
millimeters back so typing in 800
pressing minus i can go ahead and delete
that last set of tiles as well
personally i've thought long and hard
about what this bathroom should be like
because it is my everyday bathroom and
it is something that i'd like to look a
lot nicer so looking at this in 3d we
see that the space remains pretty much
the same as what it was 30 seconds ago
if i marquee that space we'll see that
we still have our tiles we have all of
our walls and we have a very small
window that basically does nothing in
that bathroom personally i would also
demolish and rebuild this window as well
let's go ahead and delete that window so
we have a fresh clean slate to me
walking in from the central position of
this bathroom is a logical space so
that's fine we don't want to mess with
the outside flow of the bedroom itself
we do just want to mess with what's
happening on the inside in my
professional opinion i always believe
that if you have the budget for it you
tile from floor to ceiling every single
time because bathrooms are wet areas
they get destroyed they get mold they
get all sorts of things all over the
walls and it's so much easier to clean
tiles than it is to clean plasterboard
so in this instance i'd be using a
polished plaster product that could be
used on the floor as well as the walls
that would act instead of a tile the
media actually be able to do that and
articulate that in 3d in twin motion
i'll go show all select my slab for
starters command t
change my tiles let's change that to
paint shale gray for the time being just
so we designate the same color i'm also
going to paint the interior of all of my
walls that same color and the blade wall
that i've created entirely in shale gray
now as you can see we have the inside of
our bathroom completely created as the
shale gray or polish plaster product
personally i like to work with a three
color scheme so in this instance i'll be
working with timber the light gray which
is the concrete and the black as well
let's come back into our ground floor
plan and map out what we're going to do
personally i believe that the shower
should be on the right hand side so once
you walk in you have the option of left
and right your vanity should be in the
middle as you walk in and then your
toilet can continue to be on the left so
let's start by creating some cabinetry
behind the toilet personally i think it
is a complete waste of space to have
nothing behind the toilet so i always
like to use a concealed toilet system
and then use the surrounding space as
cabinetry okay so i've dropped in the
cabinetry here on the left hand side in
front of my toilet so the toilet will be
able to sit behind this concealed system
panel there'll be two panels on the
right hand side if i change my settings
to construction we'll see the handles
that i've created we have one wood
cabinet on the left one wood cabinet on
the right two above and a bulkhead for
our grand sealing feature which will
come in soon i want to include a toilet
on the left hand side that is a wall
mounted toilet so this is currently what
i have as my setup if we come into 3d
we'll see that toilet created perfectly
in line where it needs to be with the
flush plate just above the lid as well
if we marquee that space it gives you a
much better much clearer overview now
like i said the vanity should be in the
middle of this space so we're simply
going to use a multi-basin cabinetry 25
these are the current settings i have
set up for this individual cabinetry
along with the tap style 2 as well wall
mounted moving back into our 3d space we
see that our cabinetry is now centrally
aligned to our space we have that
polished plaster in the background and
we have a unique ability to create a
walk-in shower on the right-hand side
now for me there are three elements that
make up a good shower first of all it
has to be walk-in so let's create a wall
on the right-hand side we have our
walk-in shower here on the right-hand
side if we go to 3d we'll see we have
our polish plus the wall on the
right-hand side coming up to the vanity
basin and then glass above personally i
like to have glass still even though
it's a pain and a nuisance to wipe down
all the time because it lets an
abundance of natural light into that
space and you're not blocking any light
by creating wall next you want to
introduce your rain head shower or any
particular shower head style that you
like and last but not least we don't
want to forget about our channel drain
or our cut off when you have an open
shower in my personal belief there
usually should be at least a 10 to 20
millimeter set down in that shower so
the water can't come out and also a
channel drain right of edge so when the
water does flow out it doesn't go past
now some people like to have their
channel drains on the opposite side or
directly behind the shower like in this
instance here however this is just my
personal preference and you can put your
channel drains wherever you personally
like however i much prefer to stop the
water before it comes out to the door
now we are missing a couple more things
first of all we're missing the window
that we need to install into this
bathroom setup and we're missing some
sort of beautiful mirror decoration and
some feature lighting now the ceiling
could be your feature lighting you could
have additional feature lighting
personally i like to create moody
inviting spaces where showers are a
little bit more poetic rather than just
stale and white and boring so for me to
create something a little bit different
i would like to introduce a half moon
mirror with two pendant lights on the
right hand side to create that we can
simply use our slab tool from the start
and then convert it to a morph by
converting it to a morph we can
instantly create our mirror in the
background cutting it in line with our
wall and also duplicating it so we have
some sort of glass 3d element behind
that we can articulate led light in twin
motion now quickly point out if you
would like a copy of this file or any
file i create on archicad on youtube you
can get it through the patreon link
below it is one of the very first links
so be sure to check it out when you get
a spare moment now if you don't want to
go overboard and you don't want to do
ceiling feature lighting i'd suggest two
feature pendants on the right hand side
here of this vanity basin something
similar to these teardrop pendant lights
that i've simply created using different
sets of columns so that's a 10
millimeter column 760 high 1640 above
the ground same information for that one
and last but not least i've manipulated
a third column in the middle to create
it as a actual glass lamp now if i were
to renovate this bathroom i would
genuinely go all out and i would spare
no expense that means that introduce
some sort of feature ceiling to the
design the design itself is relatively
simple and we have the added benefit of
the bathroom already having a 2 7
ceiling so we can introduce a drop
bulkhead in down to 2.4 2.6 or to
whatever we really want to create the
feature we're looking for personally i
think it would look really nice if we
were able to emulate two drop timber
bulkheads so one above the toilet and
one above the actual bathroom space that
can be simply created by offsetting two
slabs 150 millimeters from each edge and
duplicating them across so to show you
what that looks like in 3d basically
what i've done is created one slab and a
second slab both in timber two lamp
sources underneath which are again just
50 millimeter high concrete slabs with
lamp settings attached and then the
ceiling created in 3d that was
originally there i just never designed
it before so the ceiling i'd most likely
also create in a polished plaster so
that if anything went wrong you could
wipe it down very very easily so if we
change that to shallow gray all over
it'll create that automatically in twin
motion when we start adding our
materials now from an architectural
point of view if we come back to our
floor plan we'll see that we enter
through that same cavity slider that was
originally there we've manipulated none
of the exterior walls we've just gutted
the internal i know that the petition
walls are all timber frame and i know
that the slab is concrete so we will
have to cut new concrete channels into
the actual slab to be able to get our
drainage across we'll be able to
manipulate this vanity because it's very
similar to the location it is now but
the shower is going to be our biggest
challenge nonetheless by putting the
shower here we have the perfect ability
to introduce a brand new window on the
right hand side which is significantly
larger so if i introduce a new window i
would make that a top hung sliding
window that basically the whole top
panel drops down and introduce it into
our space i'd make sure it is
approximately the same size as this
opening and as far away from the shower
as possible and also introduce a 45
degree sill so that all the water that
may potentially fall onto that window
naturally drains away back into the
shower reviewing that in 3d we'll see
that we have our top panel able to slide
down and let all that natural light and
natural ventilation into the space we'll
see we have a shower on the right and we
have our beautiful space that allows
much much more natural light and is
significantly more usable than the
previous reiteration of this bathroom
space now that design is basically
everything that we're going to do in
archicad 25 we are now going to take
this into twin motion and create a
beautiful 3d render of the space in a
matter of minutes we've converted our
archicad model into a twin motion file
and transferred it across
we can start manipulating and working on
this environment as you can see it's
just a portable cube at the moment i've
sectional marking that space and taking
out that front main wall so we can get a
beautiful image front on
at the moment the location is completely
wrong and irrelevant so what we're going
to start doing is start by changing the
location let's change that to perth
western australia which is where i am at
the moment let's say about 12 30 in the
afternoon is a good time and i'll also
adjust the north point across so we get
that natural light coming in through
that window perfectly to emphasize the
addition of the window space next i'm
going to change the background to none
because we don't need any information
there and also change our weather
settings to a little bit of cloud just
to give it that harsh contrast the most
important thing in the environment now
is to simply adjust the material of our
floor so if we can find where our axis
north point is we can drag that up a
little bit just to the bottom of that
slab
and change that to my personal favorite
plastic
red replace and change the color to pure
white now we also want to take the
reflection all the way down so we don't
get any sharp harsh elements coming back
and bouncing back into our space we can
now start working on our actual
environment and what we've created in
archicad the simplest way to start is by
starting with the environment itself
which we are creating that polish
plaster look so going into materials
concrete we'll just use a simple base
concrete look i'll drag that up to maybe
three times the scale to be able to get
some texture in next i'm going to come
all the way down to neon lights and
introduce my neon lights into my lamp
elements so i have lamp elements
dedicated behind the mirror in the two
lights and also above the bulkheads
themselves
they are the main features of this
bathroom next we want to change the
glass in between our shower and our main
bathroom space to two-sided glass and
reflective on the actual outside of our
space finally we want to introduce
mirror into our actual mirror and change
the wood to something a little bit nicer
and a little bit lighter in color so
personally i'm just going to use the ash
timber on the both the bulkhead and also
the vanity itself and the background
cabinetry and then we have our finished
bathroom layout completely redesigned
completely brand new extremely different
to what we started
extremely luxurious but not spending an
absurd amount of money compared to what
you could do by simply just changing the
colors of the bathroom and achieving
nothing functionally from it so overall
i think this is the best bathroom design
for the space that we're working with
and i hope that this gives you some
inspiration to be able to create
something fantastic in your next
bathroom renovation anyway that is all
for me today guys thank you so much for
watching make sure you smash the like
button and the subscribe button if you
enjoyed this content and like always
i'll see you next monday